- Is it true that you,
you were once in a stage
version- I love this,
of "Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure"?
- Yeah, that was the play we did
in my senior year of high school.
- I love that this is a play.
- This is cool.
- Oh yeah.
- I know.
I, ours were like, I mean, they were fine
but they were the classic
ones everybody always does.
I just thought that was
very progressive and cool.
- Oh, well it was,
I didn't take the drama
class, but the kids who did,
their assignment was to write this play,
and adapt a play, and they chose
"Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure."
And so one of my,
friends from football and
rugby, M.C., he was like,
"Yeah, like I'm writing it.
Come audition to be Bill and like
let's audition together as Bill and Ted."
And we did and we both got it.
- Oh my gosh.
- That is so fun.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- It was a lot of fun.
- I, no, this is not a joke.
I literally learned
certain historical figures
(Amy laughs)
- from that movie.
- We'll take education
wherever we can get it.
- I was like, look,
before Hamilton came around
I was learning from Bill and Ted. (laughs)
- Yep.
- [Gabriel] Oh yeah.
- Socrates.
- It's entertaining,
and something historical
you're learning about.
So what's the strangest
play you've ever done?
- Ooh, wow. God that's a good question.
I feel like I was a snow,
like a, a snowflake.
- Oh, wow.
(Kelly laughs)
- In like in second or third grade.
And she didn't really have an arc.
We don't, we don't know
what her character was.
It was, it was, it was a mess.
(Kelly laughing)
- Well hey, there are no small parts.
There's only small actors.
- That's right.
- Oh, okay, I like that.
Is that a thing people
say? I've never heard that?
- [Amy] Yeah.
- Oh, I'm not an actor.
- They usually say it to the
people that have small parts.
(Kelly, Gabriel, and Amy laughing)